merci bertrand le sicop se déroule
jusqu'à la fin de la semaine à paris et
cette année il montre les grands progrès
de l'informatique notamment à travers
l'utilisation de l'image l'image ce
n'est pas fait simplement pour s'amuser
vous allez d'ailleurs en avoir
maintenant la preuve avec le repos
retarde le reportage de guy schwartz et
yves barbe
vous allez vous apercevoir qu une
entreprise qui fabrique des petites
voitures dans la région l'onu lyonnaise
et bien utilise l'image informatique
pour une meilleure performance de ces
petits objets pour dessiner les
premières esquisses de ce que sera le
futur jouets miniatures
on part tout simplement chez majorette
de photos ou de catalogue fourni par le
constructeur automobile concernés on
dessine d'abord sur l'écran les formes
générales de la voiture sur deux
dimensions des formes que l'on peut
modifier à volonté
et lorsque l'on est satisfait on passe
automatiquement à la troisième dimension
à ce stade toutes les cotes de la
voiture ont été calculés par
l'ordinateur
on a donc réalisé ce qu'on appelle la
conception assistée par ordinateur la
ceao mais le système informatique ne
restent pas là en effet désormais il va
être capable de définir les ordres à
donner aux machines outils dit à
commande numérique c'est à dire en fait
des machines outils piloter elle même
par ordinateur ces machines sont en
effet fabriquées les matrices destinée à
l'élaboration des moules dans lesquelles
les jouets seront produits installé
depuis le début de l'année chez
majorette ce système de conception et de
fabrication assistée par ordinateur la
cfao présente un énorme avantage pour un
industriel qui cale que ces produits sur
les modèles lancés par les constructeurs
automobiles à gagner beaucoup de temps
sur les délais de sortie les modèles
par exemple sur un modèle deux sens une
petite voiture miniature on va gagner
simon sur le délai totalement passée de
12 à 14 en moyenne actuellement 1,6 me
faire appel à des technologies aussi
avancé ça pose des problèmes en terme de
formation au personnel non il faut
compter pour un utilisateur pour les
gens qui travaillent ici quinze jours de
formation théorique c'est une personne
du constructeur qui vient chez nous
former les gens et ensuite il ya quatre
à cinq mois de formation pratique avec
des cas concrets qui correspondent à
notre application
l'investissement total a coûté 5
millions de francs à majorettes il
devrait être amorti en moins de sept ans
et cela sans réduction d'effectif du
moins dans l'entreprise puisque le gain
de temps tenue sera compensée par le
rapatriement d'un certain nombre de
travaux d'usinage jusqu'à présent sous
traiter à l'extérieur